the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
alright my friends in this video i will
finally show you what happens in my next
episode of game of thrones season 9. as
you all know i have been writing my own
season of the show now i do want to say
i am sorry it has been so long since the
release of my last episode i should have
made this video a lot sooner i want to
thank all of you who are still invested
in my version of the following events
hopefully you will enjoy these last
episodes as this season reaches the end
now for those of you who don't remember
let me go over some of the things that
happened in the last episode otherwise
this one might not make any sense the
very last thing we saw in that episode
was the resurrection of dany's dragon
rhaegal after holding one of their
sacred ceremonies on the beach of
dragonstone the children of the forest
were able to bring him back by using
their ancient magic once the dragon was
lifted from the ocean it vanished into
the night sky as it was heading for a
destination unknown as of right now
almost every main character who is still
alive are on their way to king's landing
arya gendry and about 500 of his
bannermen are heading there now arya is
hoping she can find out why bran sent
the assassin after her daenerys drogon
grey worm kinvara macaro and all of the
slave soldiers of the fiery hand are
heading for king's landing as well
jon snow helen reed and giants bane will
also be there soon they left winterfell
in the last episode they also have
several hundred north men with them all
of these characters will arrive in
king's landing in this episode it won't
be long before they all find out exactly
what's happening with their king brandon
stark if only they knew what was
happening in the capital of westeros at
this very moment when we were last in
king's landing bran stark was moments
away from executing several members of
his small council everyone was gathered
outside watching as lore tyrion
lannister was on his knees in front of
the executioner's block waiting for his
beheading if you remember brienne was
given an option bran stark said she
could either execute tyrion lannister or
her and sarpodric would hang he said the
sword or the noose now brienne said she
could not make that choice however once
the nooses were around their necks and
the floor fell out from under their feet
brienne shouted a single word the word
she said was sword that means she agreed
to execute lord tyrion so she could save
herself and sir podrick now let me show
you what happens next in season 9
episode 8. this episode is named burn
them all shall we begin
in the very first scene of this episode
we are back in king's landing there is
still a massive crowd gathered around
outside of the red key all of their eyes
are focused on what is happening up on
the center stage in front of them
samwell davos as well as everyone else
who is standing around them are watching
in silence as brienne and sir podrake
are cut down from their nooses as soon
as their bodies hit the ground they
immediately start gasping for breath
lord tyrion lannister's head rises from
the executioner's block he looks behind
him shocked by what he heard brienne is
slowly getting back on her feet but it's
not easy while her hands are still bound
behind her back when she looks over at
tyrion all he can do is shake his head
no there is sadness in her eyes again
but only for a moment now she looks away
as one of the members of the king's
guard begins walking over her way he's
holding a small blade in his right hand
he grabs brianne by the shoulder then
moves her so he can free the rope that's
wrapped around her hands he does the
same thing for sir podrick who is now
standing up on his feet as well sam
looks over at davos unsure of what will
happen next lady berean says a voice
from the other end of the stage everyone
looks over at bran stark who has a
member of his new king's guard standing
on his right and left side laying across
his lap is oath keeper brianne's
valerian steel sword lady berean says
brain again as he lifts up her sword in
the air he says i believe you are asking
for this the sword is yours and you and
sir podrick will be free to go but first
you must lay lortyrian's head at my feet
remember the sword or the noose i will
not ask you again says bran the member
of the kingsguard walks back across the
stage he is then handed brianne's
valyrian steel sword sam and davis watch
as the man walks back across the stage
again now holding the sword out in front
of him every one of the onlookers and
the crowd are silent as a crypt the
king's guardman stops when he is
standing before brienne he hands her the
sword then steps off to the side
brienne grabs a firm grip around
oathkeeper's handle with both hands she
looks over at bran as well as the other
king's guard men who are standing at his
right and left side then she looks over
at sarpodric who is ever so slightly
shaking his head now brienne extends her
arms out in front of her the reflection
of the sun bounces off her sword she
begins resting the blade on the back of
lord tyrion's neck as she takes in
another deep breath the edge of oath
keeper is so sharp you can already see a
drop of blood on the back of the neck
where the blade is resting brienne
slowly raises the sword high above her
head
lord tyrion shuts his eyes as his body
begins to involuntarily shake as soon as
the blade begins to fall from the sky
brienne does a sidestep then swings the
sword around with her arms now fully
extended in one swift motion oathkeeper
slices all the way through the neck of
the kingsguard men standing at her side
his head goes bouncing off the stage
into the crowd a thick rope of blood
shoots out of his neck six feet into the
sky
the crowd of onlookers below erupt into
absolute chaos the king's guardman who
is standing at bran's left side begins
rushing forward as soon as brianne sees
him their blades come crashing into each
other the sound of steel slamming
against steel can be heard echoing
throughout the city square sir podrick
runs over and grabs the sword from the
headless body laying in front of him he
immediately starts cutting the
restraints around davos and sam's hands
when davos is set free he grabs the
small blade from the headless
kingsguardman then he helps lortyrion
with the rope around his hands and feet
brienne's sword smashes against the
other member of the kingsguard sword
again only now it knocks it free from
his hand before his sword even hits the
ground brienne drives her own right
through his stomach and out of his back
as soon as she yanks it back out his
lifeless body collapses brienne then
drops down on one knee hoping to find
her breath everything happens so fast
it's almost as if everyone on stage is
in a daze davos sam and the others all
look at each other stunned by what just
happened half of the crowd standing down
below begins to leave now that the show
is over the other half finally goes
silent as they wonder what will happen
now
suddenly brianne stands back up on her
feet she then begins walking back and
forth across the stage looking at
everything and everyone around her after
several moments of this brienne finally
says where is bran there was an anger in
her voice that none of them heard from
her before they all begin desperately
looking around the stage somehow bran
must have escaped after the fighting
broke out brienne looks at them in
disbelief this scene ends after she says
he couldn't have gone far in the
following scene we go right outside of
the city we can see kings landing in the
distance maybe only a few miles away it
looks as if there are hundreds of ravens
circling above the castle arya stark
suddenly stops her horse gendry does the
same before he says why are we stopping
here we're almost there arya looks up
into the sky above them searching to see
if any ravens are following when she
doesn't see any arya says i don't want
us marching 500 men right up to the
gates we don't want everyone in that
city thinking we're here for a fight we
gotta find my brother bran before any of
his guards find us first we also need to
find a boat i know of a way we can get
into the castle undetected gendry smiles
then says i'm sure you do
go find me the commander says arya i
will need to speak to him before we
leave gendry whistles then motions for
one of the men who is standing at the
front of the line arya and gendry hop
down from their horses as the commander
steps forward arya says we will need you
and all of your men to wait here gendry
and i will head into the city first if
we need your assistance we will give a
signal we will be ready when you are
says the commander we follow arya and
gendry as they walk down the hill behind
them before they begin walking along the
bank of the blackwater rush the sun in
the sky is slowly starting to hide
behind the horizon
there are several men fishing on the
other side of the shore but neither of
them notice arya or gendry they end up
walking one and a half miles before they
find a dock that has a boat without
hesitation arya grabs her dagger slices
the rope securing it to the dock then
jumps in gendry shoves the boat away
from the dock before he jumps in himself
the fast flowing water dumps them right
out onto the blackwater bay within
minutes they stay right along the
shoreline until they're directly under
the red key
once they're under the castle gendry
hops out and brings the small boat up
onto the beach
after arya gets out her eyes shoot back
out across the blackwater bay arya is
shocked when she suddenly notices
something unexpected there is a massive
black dragon filling the sky up above
and right below it on the bay is what
looks like 100 ships heading their way
gendry's eyes are now filled with fear
he says we must hurry my lady those are
the banners of the lord of light they
have somehow taken over daenerys dragon
i'm not so sure of that arya says if
that's drogon then i'm afraid daenerys
is with them you were there when the
hound killed barrack dondarrion the lord
of light brought him back right before
our very own eyes if they somehow have
daenerys body she's alive gendry knows
he has seen a resurrection before but
he's still shocked at the thought of
daenerys coming back on her dragon look
again says arya gendry's eyes follow
hers back out onto the blackwater bay
they can now see the banners of house
targaryen flapping above some of those
ships when gendry looks back at her in
disbelief arya shouts let's go the scene
ends after arya and gendry vanish into
the sewage drain in the following scene
we are suddenly on the other side of the
city in front of its main gate well i
should say this is where the main gate
was it's no longer there since drogon
blew it wide open with his dragon flame
there are about a dozen masons finishing
some stone work before it gets dark but
there's still a big hole where the
city's main gate used to be there is
also several men of the city watch
standing there on guard one of the men
from the city watch begins walking
forward after he sees a large force
heading his way right in front of him
are jon snow helen reed and tormund
giantsbane who have arrived at king's
landing as well almost every main
character who is still alive are now
here now unlike arya and gendry jon has
brought all of his men with him to the
city there are several hundred soldiers
standing behind jon and the others this
is exactly where jon stood moments
before the battle of king's landing
begun as the man from the city watch
walks forward helen reed stands beside
jon then whispers she's here john looks
over at him before he says who is here
my lord helen reed diverts his eyes to
the sky as he looks off into the
distance see for yourself says helen
reed john's eyes look out across the
city at first all he sees is the red
keep on the other side of king's landing
but as he looks up further above the
castle he suddenly notices black wings
in the sky john now has a dreadful look
on his face after he recognizes drogon
flying in front of the moon in the
distance he remembers what he did to the
men who murdered him he wonders if dany
will want to do the same thing jon
suddenly finds himself reaching for a
sword but he shifts his focus once the
man from the city watch stops in front
of him what is the meaning of this says
the gold cloak why are there hundreds of
soldiers standing outside of our gates i
need to see the king right away says
john i don't think so says the man of
the city watch you can't just show up
here like this and expect to see the
king whenever you want i would suggest
that you and your men go back but the
man is interrupted by thormann
giantsbane before he can ever finish his
sentence this is when tormund says we
did not march all of this way to ask you
for permission we are entering this city
one way or another now you can either
step aside and let us in or i will go
through you myself we're not here to
fight with you says alan reed we're here
because the king is in danger we want to
help him then helen reed lifts a finger
into the sky and says besides i would be
more worried about that than i would be
with us when the man of the city watch
looks over his shoulder his mouth hangs
open in shock once he sees a dragon
circling above the red key he says
nothing as jon and all of his men begin
walking forward into the city the scene
ends as we watch them head right for the
king's castle in the following scene we
are now in the dungeons of the red key
arya stark and gendry are making their
way into the castle's dark underbelly
when they walk out of one of the black
hallways arya notices the dragon skulls
up ahead we're almost there says arya
follow me they walk over to where there
are a long flight of stairs leading up
to the main level of the castle they
slowly and silently walk up each step
arya grabs her dagger as they emerge
from the shadows then out onto the main
floor after a few moments she looks back
over her shoulder at gendry in disbelief
there's no guard says arya that doesn't
make any sense it almost feels as if the
castle is empty they stay against the
wall as they walk on the other side of
the hall now they enter the hall that
was once the home of the iron throne
there are still a few ravens walking
along the floor
gendry motions in the direction where
the iron throne once set there are some
bones scattered across the floor as well
what in the seven hells happened here
gendry wondered this castle has become a
graveyard they exit the great hall
now they walk across the small council
room then over the map of westeros
that's on the floor there is a full moon
up in the sky above them but it vanishes
after drogon flaps his massive black
wings in front of it let's go caesarea
as they begin ascending the stairs they
suddenly hear the sound of a voice they
can see bran's doris slightly open
before they even reach it arya
immediately swings open his door with
her right hand while she holds her
valyrian steel dagger and her left hand
once they are inside the room they are
unexpectedly greeted by sir davos
samwell brianne sarpodrick and lorterion
they're all stunned when they see arya
walking through that door lady arya says
brienne why are you back in king's
landing i thought you were leaving
westeros for good so did i says arya
that was until an assassin was waiting
for me in the cabin on my ship i wasn't
sure if i should believe the man or not
but the unknown man said that bran was
the one who hired him to kill me i'm
here to find out what's wrong with my
brother i guess he wants me dead you're
not the only one says lortyrian he wants
all of us dead he would have been
successful if it wasn't for brienne
saving our lives whereas brain at now
ask gendry we don't know says davos one
minute he was here then the next he was
gone we need to find him right away says
arya they're suddenly interrupted by a
thunderous sound that only could have
come from a dragon the sound of dread
can be heard in lore tyrion's voice when
he says what the hell was that you know
what that sound was says arya you were
around the dragons longer than any of us
it looks like daenerys is back from the
dead she has a hundred ships right
outside of the city walls everyone looks
a bit shaken up by the revelation no one
says a word for a few moments finally
davos says well the fact that we're not
all burning alive right now might be a
good sign that she's not here for a
fight if that really is drogon above us
we would be dead already if that's what
she wanted davos's words ease some of
the nervousness in the room but arya
doesn't look so sure about that arya
grabs the burning torch out of gendry's
hand before walking out onto the balcony
of the king's chambers she begins waving
it back and forth in the air giving the
signal to the men waiting outside of the
city when arya walks back inside she
says well we're about to find out
exactly what daenerys wants if it is a
fight that she wants we will give her
one gendry let's move arya and gendry
exit the room before heading back down
the stairs unsure of what to do next
brienne sam davos tyrion and sir podrick
follow right behind them all of them
walk across the painted map of westeros
then through the small council room
before heading down the hallway that
leads into the great hall where the iron
throne was once located after they enter
the great hall they suddenly stop when
they hear the sound of loud footsteps
walking their way arya and brienne reach
for their weapon one of the ravens lets
out a loud shriek before it starts
circling above their heads near the
ceiling finally there are shadows that
emerge from the darkness on the other
side of the great hall arya gendry
brienne sarpodric davos sam and
lorterion watch as they slowly walk
their way daenerys targaryen has
officially arrived walking in front of
her is grey worm as well as several of
his unsolid men they already have their
weapons in hand on dany's right and left
side are kanvara and makaro walking
behind them are about a dozen slave
soldiers of the fiery hand lord tyrion
lannister has a fearful look in his eyes
he almost looks as if he'd just seen a
ghost the silence is interrupted by a
thunderous scream as drogon lands on the
roof of the red key the ceiling begins
shaking as the dragon walks over to
where there is still a large opening in
the castle wall
the moonlight is glimmering off of his
shiny black scales his dark red eyes
never leave daenerys as he watches over
his mother in the great hall when they
reach the center of the room greyworm
and his unsullied men step aside as can
vara and makaro step forward in a loud
booming voice that echoes throughout the
hall makaro says my friends we are here
on this night on behalf of our lord of
light he then looks over at arya when he
says unfortunately a darkness rises
again it has fallen over westeros
already yet it threatens our very
existence as it sweeps over the entire
realm the great other has your brother
as we speak we must act fast will you
stand beside us as we bring the light
back into all of our lives again davos
brienne sam and tyrion all look at each
other in disbelief i don't understand
says arya i killed the night king i
watched as his army fell right before my
very own eyes what are you saying
makaro's dark shining eyes study
everyone in the great hall as he says
the night king was simply an instrument
of the great other just as we are simply
an instrument of the lord of light why
do you think your brother tried to have
you killed there was a wariness in
arya's voice as she asked him how did
you know about that makaro smiles before
he says i have seen this and much more
and were lower sacred flames he then
looks back at daenerys and says the lord
of light has shown me daenerys
stormborn's worth that's why we stand
beside her now every night in my fires i
have glimpsed the glory that awaits her
is that right arya says angrily did this
lord of light show you what daenerys did
to this city i saw that with my own eyes
as well i was down there in those city
streets watching as her and her dragon
burned innocent women and children is
that this glory that you speak of now if
that's not darkness falling over
westeros then i don't know what is
the lady arya is right whispered a voice
from the shadows there was a darkness
within daenerys and even her dragon as
she burned the city to the ground it was
the same darkness that lives within your
brother brandon stark now who said that
asked arya do you know where my brother
is a moment goes by before the man
behind the voice steps out of the
shadows my name is alan reed my lady i
know where your brother is and i know
what is wrong with him i'm afraid the
great other has him now and all of us
must leave soon if we want to live some
of the anger leaves arya's eyes as she
says you are friends with my father i
was my lady says helen reed arya looks
at kinvara and makaro then back at alan
reed before she says both of you speak
of this great other yet i don't know
what that is who are they where are they
and what do they want with bran
well it's just as he said says helen
reed
your brother is simply their instrument
no different than the night king was
before they created the night king after
all and they were living inside of his
mind the same way that they are inside
of brain's mind now there is an island
not far from here known as the isle of
faces some of you may know it as the
god's eye on this sacred isle lives some
of the wisest and eldest living members
of the children of the forest they have
been living there since before the first
man ever stepped foot on westerosi soil
they are extremely dangerous and their
veins have been filled with hatred for
thousands of years they want the same
thing daenerys wanted they want what
they believe is rightfully theirs
they want back all of the land that man
stole from them and they will stop at
nothing unless every last one of us are
dead lord tyrion who has been standing
behind everyone else finally steps
forward a hint of anger flashes across
dany's face after she sees him so they
have been inside of bran's mind making
him kill all of us says tyrion i'm
afraid so says helen reed after a moment
of silence lord tyrion whispers why do
you think i came all this way this
immediately gets the attention of arya
sam davos gendry and brienne they all
remember hearing bran say that right
before he was named king he knew
cysterian he knew exactly what would
happen after i suggested we name bran as
our new king he said why do you think i
came all this way it's as if everything
happened exactly the way he wanted he
knew we would defeat the army of the
dead after a sadness fills his eyes lord
tyrion looks at dany then says
he knew daenerys would burn king's
landing he then sits down after suddenly
feeling a bit dizzy finally dany says
did they orchestrate everything while
she is looking at lord helen reed yes
they did said a familiar voice from the
shadows as jon snow emerges from the
darkness he says everyone was exactly
where they were supposed to be
that was the very last thing bran said
to me right before he shipped me off to
spend the rest of my life at castle
black when drogon sees jon again he lets
out a thunderous scream so loud it feels
as if it shook the very foundation of
the castle the ravens that were circling
around the great hall immediately
scatter into the wind it looks like the
wind has been knocked right out of
daenerys after she sees jon for herself
greyworm and the unsullied ready their
weapons immediately arya and brienne do
the same when kinvara and makaro notice
this they step in front of jon hoping to
avoid any bloodshed just yet your grace
john says nervously
i'm sorry for what happened i did not
know then what i'm beginning to
understand now lord tyrion is right bran
or i should say the children of the
forest knew exactly what would happen
they wanted all of us to destroy each
other i finally understand why bahrain
said i was exactly where i was supposed
to be he knew you would burn down king's
landing he must have seen it in one of
his visions and he knew that i would
execute you for that now i see why he so
easily sent me to the wall he needed me
out of the way but only after i did what
he knew i would do john then looks at
arya and says that's why he sent an
assassin after you he saw you kill the
night king he knew you would be one of
his biggest threats he had to get rid of
you the same way he was getting rid of
all of us once they had the iron throne
they no longer needed any of us don't
you see that now
brian
i'm not really
you died in that cave
you're a man
almost
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
if we choose you
will you wear the crown
[Music]
why do you think i came all this way
to go through all of that and
make your way home again only to find
such
chaos in the world
i can only imagine chaos is a
ladder the great hall is suddenly as
silent as a crypt everyone is looking
around at each other in disbelief but
also realizing what has been happening
all along
daenerys begins walking forward out from
behind all of her guards grey worm goes
to stop her but she lays her hand on his
before shaking her head no
she walks out across the great hall
until she is standing in front of helen
reed and jon snow dany looks in john's
eyes for several moments as she thinks
about everything that has been said she
looks over at helen reed then says i
guess now there is only one thing i want
to know how can we defeat them once and
for all
the scene ends right after helen reed
says
well we will defeat them the same way
they were using you and your dragon to
kill everyone in this city we will burn
them all in the final scene of this
episode we are back on the shore of the
isle of faces this scene begins by us
getting a good look at the full moon
that is sitting above the god's eye
there are hundreds of ravens circling in
the sky above all of the island's sacred
werewoods we watch as shadows shift
around in the woods no different than
any other night the green men are
getting ready to stand their silent
watch as they guard the isle of faces
thousands of little green men begin
emerging from within the woods as always
all of them are holding weapons of their
own their weapons are made up of
different dragonglass some of them are
black green and even red the faces on
the werewoods behind them are somehow
more frightening than they were before
they have hatred in their blood red eyes
they all have been sitting here silently
watching and waiting for thousands of
years it makes you wonder how many
horrific sacrifices they have seen over
those several millennia as soon as all
of the green men are standing in a
circle around the whole island something
else begins shifting in the shadows the
sound of branches breaking and the
leaves crunching under the footsteps is
very reminiscent of the sound of bones
breaking the little green men are not
the only ones watching and waiting on
this evening suddenly what looks like
100 000 glowing blue eyes begin emerging
from the darkness within the forest this
massive army is made up of nothing but
white walkers who are still riding on
the back of their giant elks only these
white walkers look slightly different
than the ones we've seen before
now as frightening as they look they
also have a bit of elegance to them
sort of like a haunting beauty
all of them begin surrounding the sacred
island as well
they're ready for whatever is heading
their way now we begin to move to the
center of the island where the largest
werewood in westeros is located
once again we see the grove of seven
werewolves that are all facing inward at
each other right in the center of them
is a massive werewood with a very large
open mouth on its face there are bones
and skulls scattered all around the
werewoods on the floor of the forest
this is where the episode will end the
final thing we see is what's inside this
massive weirwood the episode will fade
to black after we get a glimpse of
brandon stark sitting in this mouth of
madness like the three i'd raven before
brandon stark is entangled by the roots
of the weirwood it looks like the
children of the forest have made this
his new home
a home that he will never be able to
leave again
so
you